after a monstrously long wait fans of
Netflix says The Witcher have finally
gotten a good look at what the series
third season has to offer and while our
heroes definitely seem stronger the
threats seem much bigger too
the trailer opens with a shot of a
majestic statue of a woman in armor
holding a spear Siri geralt and yennefer
approach it despite its surroundings and
what appears to be ruins the statue
seems to be relatively Untouched by time
the woman depicted in the Statue is Lara
Doran an ancient elf sorceress of great
power who was a legend to the Elven
people her descendants called Children
of the Elder blood have inherited
Laura's Powers Siri doesn't yet realize
that she is the most reason to possess
the gene that grants her this power
which explains her unusual magic ability
in the first episode of the second
season geralt's friend Neville and tells
Siri the story of how Laura fell in love
with the human man and it all ended
tragically though he does not reveal her
name
child born to parents dead that faithful
when
day Laura also made a brief appearance
in the second season's fifth episode
when Tris convinces Siri to let her
perform the dolducia a spell that
enables Tris to go deep into Siri's
unconscious mind within Siri's
Dreamscape she and tris come across an
elf woman bleeding from a fatal wound as
she Comforts her newborn child Siri
recognizes the woman from netherland's
Tale But the vision takes a dark turn
when the elf begins choking Tris and
reciting an ominous prophecy to Siri
Siri's connection to Lara Doran is a
huge part of the plot in The Witcher
bucks and it seems likely that Siri will
get more answers about her lineage in
season 3 of the Netflix series
The Witcher is famous for its monsters
fighting these Abominations is part of a
witcher's livelihood after all and in
the Netflix series we've seen the white
wolf encounter some seriously
intimidating foes including quite a few
that fans May recognize from The Witcher
video games in the pilot geralt battles
a kikimura a huge insectoid creature in
season 2 geralt and Siri encounter
aleshi a demonic Forest monster that
later on proves to be esco's demise in
the trailer for season 3 Siri is
wandering through a dark maze when she
comes across a terrifying Beast with a
hard carapace shell on its back the
creature folds itself into a ball and
rolls ahead for a battering attack but
Siri jumps out of the way just in time
this looks very similar to a Shale Mar a
giant burrowing monster that made an
appearance in Blood and wine one of the
DLC chapters of The Witcher 3 the wild
Hunt the shalemart in Blood and wine had
been taken captive by Toussaint royalty
to fight in a series of tournament games
because we see the creature in a maze in
the trailer it's possible that it was
put there deliberately for a similar
purpose if perhaps a more Sinister one
of all the enemies Our Heroes have faced
so far none can hold a candle to the
terrifying Force known as the wild Hunt
Siri had only a brief but ominous
glimpse of the spectral writers in
season two
the reappearance in the season 3 trailer
promises a greater threat to come we see
Siri writing while looking back over her
shoulder presumably with the Hunt Hot on
her heels when we catch a glimpse of the
wild Hunt their black horses are adorned
with skeletal armor and the writers
themselves are shrouded and missed the
wild Hunt played an important role in
both the Witcher books and in the video
games they are inspired by a myth from
multiple European cultures in which
spectral beings would steal people away
and drag them to the underworld in The
Witcher Universe the wild Hunt are
actually from an ancient race of elves
known as the NL their leader is Eridan
Brea glass and under the command of King
Oberon of the NL his quest is to travel
between worlds and find slaves to bring
back to the elf Homeworld As Time passed
in the realm of the NL the wild Hunt
found it more difficult to travel
between worlds however they soon
discovered that those with the Elder
blood can move between the Realms since
Siri is a child of the Elder blood she's
a target for the wild Hunt
for much of the first season Siri is a
refugee on the run from nilfgaardian
Invaders her only hope is to find geralt
to whom she was sworn via the law of
surprise her powers begin to manifest in
dangerous ways and since she has no
control over them it makes her journey
all the more perilous in season two girl
takes in Syria and acts as her protector
he soon realizes that Siri must learn to
defend herself against the many enemies
seeking her out he takes her to care
more the witcher's base of operations
where Siri begins training in The
Witcher style of fighting when Siri and
yennefer finally meet Jennifer senses
the powerful magic within Siri and
offers the teacher how to use it
although Siri is reluctant Jennifer's
help proves to be invaluable the season
3 trailer shows hints of series progress
in her magical training and her fighting
skills for one series magic causes a
dead tree to suddenly Bloom back to life
and we see her smile at the
accomplishment as Yen watches Siri's
sword skills are also impressive as she
fights off scoia tell soldiers and goes
up against some gnarly beasts though she
may not technically be a Witcher it
seems that Siri has earned a place among
them in the newest season she even
alludes to the idea in a conversation
with geralt the witches is that sir
the Tower of aratusa is the seat of
magical power on the continent and has
been an important setting for all of
Netflix's The Witcher so far this is
where Yen and many other young magic
users begin their training with the
Sorceress to Saya it's also where
important political planning among the
Mages and sorceresses takes place it's
here that to Saya along with the Mage
vilgaforts went against the wishes of
stregabore to oppose nilfgaard resulting
in the devastating Battle of sodden Hill
at the end of the first season though
many Mages and sorosauruses died in the
Battle aratuza remains a strong Center
of power throughout the show's second
season in the season 3 trailer the tower
can once again be seen Standing Tall on
Bandit Island much of season 2 was based
on the first novel and author Andrei
sakovsky series Blood of Elves and
season 3 will be taking events from the
second book time of contempt at one
point in the trailer geralt and yennefer
are seen wearing formal attire attending
a ball with geralt notably wearing Yen's
preferred black and white color scheme
this event is part of a conclave of
Mages taking place in aratuza Tower and
it also happens in the book in time of
contempt Jennifer and her fellow
sorcerer Margarita hope to enroll Syria
atuza for her to better train in Magic
this training will likely play a larger
role within the story throughout season
3 and Beyond
thanks to the mutations that turn them
into witchers the renowned monster
Slayers are not only Adept at sword
fighting but are also wielders of
powerful magic these magic spells are
called signs and while there are
supposedly a countless number of these
signs there are five of them that are
the most familiar to fans of The Witcher
video games Ard yurden axi Quinn and
igne so far in the Netflix series we've
seen Geral perform art which emits a
blast of force to throw back enemies and
axi a mind control ability that aims to
calm or sway others gaming fans are sure
to recognize yet another Witcher sign in
the trailer for the third season Quinn
which creates a protective spherical
shield around the Caster it seems to
come in very handy as geralt fights off
a band of scoyatel Quinn is also an
essential mechanic in The Witcher video
games and helps the player with getting
out of tough scrapes fans of the game
still haven't seen geralt use igne which
produces fire or urden a magical trap
that slows and weakens foes in the
series just yet Perhaps we will see
these and even more signs besides these
from the games but we'll just have to
wait and see
along with new monsters in the wild Hunt
the trailer for The Witcher season 3
brings back some familiar enemies as
well the most prominent is riyence who
was played by Chris Fulton in season two
but has been recast in season 3 with Sam
Wolf the Mage with a penchant for
pyromancy was imprisoned in a Cintron
cell until getting set free by the
Sorceress Lydia who hires Ryans to
capture Siri on behalf of a mysterious
employer no matter how much riens tries
to get the identity of her boss Lydia
keeps it secret
reince tracks down yaskir and torches
him to find Siri's whereabouts only for
the bar to be rescued by Jennifer rienne
suffers severe burns after his fire
spell against Yen backfires resulting in
him getting a nasty scar on his face he
continues to chase after Siri attacking
the Temple of militelli where he and the
mercenary michillette Brothers fight
geralt as Siri escapes with yennefer
though Ryans fails to capture Siri he
does manage to get a hold of some of her
blood to take back to Lydia reince
appears once again in the trailer for
season 3 promising even more trouble for
Siri and her companions another
returning character in season 3 is
stregabore a powerful Mage with his own
nefarious agenda in the trailer we see
him standing on a balcony and looking
down probably somewhere in aratuza it's
difficult to tell what he might be up to
in future episodes but whatever it is we
can bet that it's not good the first
volume of the third season of The
Witcher comes out on Netflix on June 29
2023 and volume 2 is set to be released
on July 27 2023